[Musica]
il titolo del mio intervento da grande
voglio fare restauratore con la
restauratrice di habitat e che cosa
parliamo quando parliamo di biodiversità
nasce un po in modo provocatorio
perché ho una preoccupazione rispetto a
come nel dibattito pubblico viene
trattata la transizione ecologica la mia
percezione è che troppo peso sia dato
agli aspetti più chimico e fisici
dell'ambiente e poco agli aspetti
geologici e naturalistici
e anche le soluzioni che vengono
proposte mi sembrano molto orientate
sulla tecnologia
sull'innovazione sulla digitalizzazione
però si parli poco di soluzioni basate
sulla natura le cosiddette natural based
solution per allora cercare di dare
concretezza a questa preoccupazione
ho fatto una piccola analisi ho preso il
piano nazionale di ripresa e resilienza
che è lo strumento principale attraverso
cui verrà realizzata la transizione
ecologica e sono andato a contare delle
parole chiave ho iniziato a contare
quante volte si ripetono nel testo
parole che in qualche maniera sono
legate alla sfera appunto
dell'innovazione della digitalizzazione
della tecnologia quindi come potete
vedere alle mie spalle sono andata a
contare quante volte si ripetessero
parole come appunto innovazione o parole
che avessero la radice tecnologico
digital e ho trovato che si ripetono 782
volte quindi effettivamente questa
questo aspetto è molto valorizzato sono
andata anche a contare quante volte si
ripetessero parole con la radice
infrastrutture ho trovato 220
ripetizioni è un po mi ha colpito la
cosa perché questo termine
infrastrutture infrastrutturale non è
male e utilizzato parlando di
infrastrutture verdi che invece sono un
pilastro delle politiche europee legate
all'ambiente e alla cura del territorio
della natura
poi sono andata a contare le parole
invece che in qualche maniera sono
legate alla sfera del clima e
dell'energia che è un tema molto molto
caldo molto
dibattuto quindi ho guardato come ho
contato quante volte si ripetessero
parole come solare clima
decarbonizzazione
mobilità gas naturale o le parole che
avessero nella loro radice enerq eolica
fotovoltaica
ho trovato 471 ripetizioni quindi anche
di questo si parla è come dire a questo
aspetto si dà peso
e poi sono andato a contare quante volte
in questo documento si ripetessero
parole invece legate alla sfera
biologico naturalistica quella che mi
sta preoccupando appunto quindi è tra
l'altro ne cercate tante molte di più se
vedete rispetto alle slide che vi ho
fatto vedere precedentemente perché
insomma volevo che si emergesse questo
aspetto quindi sono andato a cercare
quante volte veniva ripetuto capitale
naturale
quando si ripetessero le parole con la
radice forest o aree protette parchi
rinaturazione
conservazione della natura ma anche
appunto servizi ecosistemici
ecosistema naturale o ecosistemi
naturali e vedete risultato 115 volte
quindi la mia preoccupazione è diventata
più più reale e la cosa un pò che mi
come dire è dispiaciuta e vedere in
questo documento utilizzato il termine
ecosistema più volte in riferimento a
ecosistemi dell'innovazione ecosistemi
di imprese ecosistemi digital digitali
del turismo tra l'altro erroneamente
appunto ripeto do molto di più che con
il suo vero significato originario
quello di ecosistema naturale perché
questo è un termine che
dall'ecologia e proprio dell'ecologia
io mi sono chiesta come mai come mai
allora si parla così poco di
biodiversità
eppure la letteratura scientifica ci sta
dicendo che la biodiversità è una
componente chiave è cruciale per
aumentare la resilienza dei nostri
territori nei nostri ecosistemi e far
fronte a perturbazioni pesanti come
stanno dimostrando di essere cambiamenti
climatici e la pandemia
negli episodi di pandemia è coinvolta la
perdita di biodiversità
perché l'uomo distruggendo gli habitat
frammentando gli habitat con le sue
attività di allevamenti intensivi
piuttosto che di commercio di animali
sta sempre di più aumentando le
interazioni uomo animali e se noi non
cambiamo invertiamo questi comportamenti
queste tendenze queste interazioni
diventeranno sempre di più e sempre con
maggior probabilità si potranno
verificare fenomeni come lo spiel out e
salto di specie
ma allora perché allora perché non si
parla ancora una volta di biodiversità
se ne parla poco forse non si conosce
bene il significato della biodiversità e
soprattutto non si conoscono i benefici
che la biodiversità porta all uomo la
biodiversità è la ricchezza della vita
sulla terra e viene espressa a tre
livelli biodiversità genetica quindi
biodiversità di popolazioni diversità di
popolazioni di una stessa specie animale
o vegetale come volete
diversità di specie molteplicità di
specie e diversità di habitat e di
ecosistemi che sono i principali
responsabili dei servizi ecosistemici
ossia di quei benefit che la natura ci
dona e senza i quali
siamo spacciati
quali sono questi benefit vi faccio
degli esempi servizio di impollinazione
cosa facciamo se non esiste più
l'impollinazione
sono tutti gli insetti impollinatori
perché non ci prendiamo cura
dell'ambiente ma anche contributo allo
scambio ossigeno co2 e stoccaggio del
carbonio oggi importante più che mai
protezione dall'erosione del suolo
protezione anche diciamo dai da rumori
da inondazioni miglioramento della
qualità dell'aria gli ecosistemi e gli
habitat sono ci forniscono materie prime
cibo fibre principi attivi che usiamo in
ambito farmaceutico o comunque per
curarci e quindi direi che la natura ci
serve e come
ora io non voglio spaventarvi con queste
immagini il pianeta sta male non vi
voglio spaventare vi voglio però
invitare a riflettere sulla necessità di
val di valorizzare la biodiversità e gli
aspetti biologici
non lo dico solo io lo dice anche il
green deal europeo lo dice la strategia
20 30 sulla biodiversità dobbiamo
decidere quanto pianeta teniamo per noi
e quanto pianeta vogliamo lasciare a
tutti gli altri esseri viventi perché
dipendiamo anche dagli altri esseri
viventi e quindi dal punto di vista
della componente biologica bisogna
andare a valorizzare di più anche questo
aspetto nella transizione ecologica e
nelle nostre attività di ripresa e
resilienza e necessario fermare la
perdita di biodiversità
non possiamo più permetterci di erodere
ulteriormente il capitale naturale ciò
che abbiamo di conservato dobbiamo
tenercelo e anzi dobbiamo proteggerlo di
più aumentando le superfici protetti ma
non basta più solo conservare ciò che è
ancora rimasto in buono stato
è necessario restaurare habitat ed
ecosistemi ciò che abbiamo degradato e
danneggiato
non a caso lo scorso anno le nazioni
unite hanno lanciato il programma un the
kid on e consiste restoration proprio
per sottolineare questa necessità
urgente di restaurare e riparare gli
habitat danneggiati
e soprattutto quello che è importante
che dobbiamo riuscire a formulare più
soluzioni basate sulla natura non
possiamo pensare che la lotta al
cambiamento climatico si esaurisca nel
momento in cui piantiamo alberi non sto
dicendo che piantare alberi non serve ma
è troppo poco dobbiamo andare a
recuperare ripristinare natura
vegetazione ecosistemi ed habitat
ma cosa vuol dire rispettare gli habitat
e allora perché forse tutti abbiamo
l'idea di cosa vuol dire restaurare le
opere d'arte ma un po meno di cosa
voglia dire restaurare un habitat per
cercare di spiegarvelo vi faccio
l'esempio di un progetto di quest'anno
responsabile scientifico è che sto
appunto svolgendo in questo in questi
anni il progetto proprio come titolo
restauro delle praterie e dell brughiere
quindi dico brughiere non pensiamo che
stanno solo in inghilterra e scozia nel
nord europa ce l'abbiamo anche in
pianura con questo progetto vogliamo
andare a restaurare appunto queste
brughiere queste brughiera teorie e
queste brughiere secche acide che stanno
nella pianura padana e in particolare in
piemonte e lombardia in siti natura 2000
la rete natura 2000 è la più intera più
importante in rete di aree protette a
livello europeo e cosa facciamo no prima
di dirvi cosa facciamo perché sono
importanti
questi habitat aridi perché come vi
dicevo sono considerati di interesse
conservazionistico a livello europeo
sono veramente ricchi di impollinatori
molto più ricchi dei boschi e delle zone
umide ci danno un servizio di
impollinazione che altri tipi di
ecosistemi non ci danno e quindi sono
estremamente importanti
ospitano una flora ricchissima anche dal
punto di vista officinale e ornamentali
e poi ospitano queste cose che noi
chiamiamo croste biologiche così a
parlarne forse uno come dire non è molto
attirato ma solo una componente fatta di
musica e di licheni che abbiamo solo in
questi tipi di habitat in pianura che
sono importanti perché vanno a sostenere
ora di più i servizi eco sistemici che
queste praterie queste brughiere possono
fornire quali ritenzione idrica
fissazione del carbonio dell'azoto e
anche produzione di sostanze principi
attivi perché nei licheni ci sono
principi attivi si è scoperto che sono
utili anche dal punto di vista medico
quali interventi si facciamo allora per
restaurare e noi italiani tagliamo gli
alberi quindi siamo in netta
controtendenza tutti ci dicono di
piantare gli alberi e noi invece li
andiamo a togliere perché dobbiamo
aprire questi habitat tagliamo specie
legnose native e non native però
lasciamo i grandi esemplari di querce o
di specie native che ormai hanno
raggiunto ragguardevoli dimensioni e
quindi questo è come dire rappresentano
comunque un bel elemento del paesaggio
comunque della biodiversità
ma poi andiamo a fare delle cose strane
tipo ribaltare il suolo nelle brughiere
questa cosa che si chiama top soil
inversion si va proprio a ribaltare a
scavare 80 centimetri di profondità si
ribalta al suolo per riportare alla luce
gli strati più profondi che sono più
minerali sono meno ricchi di nutrienti e
sono diciamo aspetti pionieri su cui poi
andiamo a spargere dei ritagli di
calluna lac all'una e il bruco e proprio
la specie chiave della brughiera e da lì
queste a questa che luna viene prelevata
da siti donatori che sono ancora in
buono stato di conservazione vengono
sparpagliati e da lì con gli anni si
dovrebbe riformare l'habitat
un'altra azione che facciamo è quella di
andare a migliorare la composizione
floristica degli habitat di questi
habitat andiamo ad arricchirli mettendo
a dimora specie erbacee tipiche che però
attenzione non andiamo a comprare nei
garden center e vengono prodotti in
vivai specializzati perché devono essere
piante prodotte a partire da materiale
di propagazione che sia tipico del luogo
nonché arrivi chissà da dove dall'olanda
o chissà cosa
e ancora per esempio con questo progetto
andiamo proprio a ri creare ex novo dei
prati aridi
utilizzando una tecnica un materiale che
si chiama fio room e che vedete appunto
nella slide centrale questo fiume o
materiale che viene raccolto da praterie
in buono stato di conservazione quindi
ancora una volta da siti donatori che in
verso la fine dell'estate quindi quando
la maggior parte delle specie erbacee è
andata in frutta e quindi contiene i
semi attraverso appunto una macchina
particolare che spazzola le erbe
raccoglie questi semi però non va a
tagliare l'erba si fa a seccare questo
materiale e in autunno si distribuisce
nei siti in cui vogliamo ricostituire la
nostra prateria e vediamo se con gli
anni questa cosa succederà però sono
tecniche comunque sono state anche
utilizzate già in altri contesti
questo progetto è iniziato nel 2019 e
finirà nel 2024
la mia speranza è che attraverso la
promozione dei risultati del progetto
attraverso la divulgazione
il diciamo problema o comunque
l'assoluzione del restauro degli habitat
entri sempre di più nelle politiche
ambientali del nostro paese nelle
diciamo politiche di transizione
ecologica soprattutto perché mi
piacerebbe che invece di dover andare
all unione europea chiedere i soldi ci
fossero delle risorse anche in italia
perché abbiamo capito che restaurare gli
habitat a serve restare lì abita
significa restaurare servizi questi
stemmi c non possiamo farne a meno per
instaurare anche bellezza perché
permettetemi comunque la natura ci offre
delle opere d'arte che non ha nulla a
che vedere con le opere d'arte di altri
di altri artisti e quindi il mio invito
è già in generation restoration grazie
[Applauso]